-I'm so happy to see you.
I feel like it's almost --
-It's tradition.
-Yes.
I was just gonna bring that up.
Around this time
is when you visit us.
-Same time next year.
-I'm so excited. Thank you.
-Yeah.
-We're November pals. Bonded.
-So happy to be here.
-You have --
I want to talk about this
'cause it's very exciting.
You have a new family member.
-I do.
-This is very exciting.
-It's a puppy named Dot?
-She's so cute.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-She was a pound and a half here
when I brought her home.
-A pound and --
-And, you know, it sounds like,
"Oh, so cute.
I can take her everywhere,
and I can put her
in my purse," you know?
But the truth is, then you get
her home and you realize,
"Oh, my God, she's so little."
-Too little.
-And it's so --
kind of too little,
because I was afraid
I was gonna step on her.
You know, she'd die.
-Yeah.
-And -- And she would
get in places and...
-Yeah, we had a dog once
that got, like,
lost behind, like, a radiator.
-Oh!
-And it wasn't --
it wasn't on or anything.
But you get afraid.
It's too little.
Also, puppies are hard.
-Puppies -- Oh, my God.
She's so little.
-[ Laughs ]
"Puppies are..."
-They're so hard,
they're so hard.
-They are really hard.
-It's like childbirth, you know?
You forget about the pain.
You would never do it again.
-No, yeah.
And then you do it again.
-And then you do it again.
But, yeah, because she --
And it's -- having --
it's worse than having --
People say,
"Oh, it's like having a baby."
It's worse.
-Yeah, babies can wear diapers.
-And they lay there.
And they lay there.
-Yeah.
-And you feed them,
you change their d--
and you hold them
for, like, a long time.
-Yeah.
-Right?
-Dogs...
-And even though
you don't sleep, you're not --
you're not chasing them around,
cleaning up their poop,
and they're not chewing
on your clothes.
-You think your dog
looks like someone, though.
-Yeah, yeah.
In the mornings.
-In the mornings,
when Dot wakes up.
-When she wakes up...
-You think she looks like....
-...she looks like Rod Stewart.
-Yeah.
And we brought a photo,
a side-by-side photo.
Let's take a look at this.
I think you're right.
Not bad.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sexy!
You also have a big milestone
coming up.
You're going to be married
to your husband for 30 years.
-Yeah, 30 years.
-Holy moly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
I know.
-How do you --
How do you celebrate 30?
-30. The sa--
Eh, the same way.
We go to dinner.
-Yeah.
-I mean -- I mean,
I thought about having --
I can maybe weave in the 30
years we've been together,
I've had maybe five parties.
-Really?
Yeah, but I just --
I think we like
just being together and quiet
and having a little wine and...
-Do you have date nights?
-We do.
We've always had
Saturday night date nights
from the time that we met,
and I look forward
to it all week.
That's my highlight of my week.
-Oh, I love that.
-Mm-hmm.
Is that, like, one of
the secrets to your marriage?
-I think so.
I think it's -- well, I think
it's definitely
carving out time.
Especially because, when we met,
my daughter had been
with me for...
Well, David and I had only been
together for two months,
and she arrived, and we were
kind of parents right away.
So I think that the honeymoon
period for us was --
was kind of interrupted.
-Yeah.
-And so we're stuck.
-You just had to raise a child.
But I think we also --
I'm just very amused by him.
And he still surprises me.
And I think we're just both
kind of intrigued by each other.
-Yeah, you're still interested
in each other.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
I want to ask you about this
very successful business
you're doing right here,
Henry Rose.
This one -- this package
is called the Slumberparty.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, this is a fragrance.
-This is a fragrance company.
-A fragrance company.
Look at how gorgeous this is.
-Yeah.
It's the -- the first
fully transparent,
EWG-verified line of premium,
genderless fine fragrances.
-Congratulations on this.
-Thank you.
-I want to --
[ Cheers and applause ]
And they're not -- they're
not named like, you know,
like, after a scent
or something.
It's more of an experience
that you've had.
-Well, I learned
through the process,
because when I started,
I started working --
because nobody else
would actually work with me.
I started work--
'Cause everyone thought
I was nuts,
which I'm a little bit.
But I started working
directly with the perfumers,
and I had to learn
a whole new language
and how to talk about it.
And they say, "Don't, don't,
don't tell us
what you think it smells like
because it will
only confuse us."
So they said, "Tell us,
where does it take you,
where does it transport you?"
And I -- And so the very first
fragrance that we locked
is Torn.
It's vanilla and, like --
It's like a spicy vanilla.
-Mm.
-And what I didn't realize,
but I learned through
the process,
was I was actually
going after the scent
of my father's cologne.
And I always really loved --
You know,
because scent memory
is really, really powerful.
You know, people talk about it,
but I didn't really --
it truly is.
It's scientific.
-Oh, yeah.
I mean,
go back to your high school
and you just smell
the high school halls,
and you're like, "Oh, my gosh.
I got to get out of here."
Yeah, it's...
-It's actually in --
The late Peggy Feury,
is something we used to use
in acting class,
which was an item of something,
like, maybe your father's,
you know?
Like your father's old sweater
or something
that can stir you up.
-Flora Carnivora.
Um...
brings me back to when
I was a little thief.
[ Laughter ]
-What was --
Was your character --
Is your thief name
Flora Carnivora?
-No, no, I was little
and roaming the neighborhood,
which I shouldn't
have been, probably.
And I would sneak into
my neighbor's garden
because we didn't
have any flowers,
and they were too much trouble
for my dad.
-Yeah.
-And I would sneak into
their garden, and --
and I -- and one day,
I got up the courage
to steal some.
And I ran home,
and I put them in a bowl,
and I crushed them up --
[ Inhales deeply ]
And I was just intox--
the smell.
And then, of course,
it started to rot.
-Yeah. Of course.
Yeah.
-And was really stinky.
So I was very disappointed.
But that was my first
failed foray
into perfumery.
-Perfume. Yeah.
-What is this one
that's upside down?
Why is it upside down?
-Because it doesn't behave.
[ Laughter ]
-This one?
-It doesn't behave.
It's, um -- it's --
It's a menace.
-Mm.
It's called Menace, yeah.
-It's called Menace.
And --
-What does it smell like?
-I actually think -- you know,
if I were gonna
pick a cologne for you...
-[ Laughing ] What?
[ Laughter ]
Why?! I'm not a menace.
I'm very well-behaved.
-I just think -- I don't know.
I imagine, like,
a Dennis the Menace thing
that maybe went on with you
when you were little.
-Never getting in trouble.
-And also the olfactive here,
I think, that you would
really love.
-Really?
-Now, what have we got here?
-But it is an aquatic musk.
So I think you need to apply it
doing the dolphin.
-Now, we discussed,
the only way I put cologne on
or any type of scent
is to dolphin into it.
-Right, right.
-I spray it,
and then I kind of get in.
-We know this about you.
-All right. So now --
So this is Menace.
-Yeah, this is Menace.
-All right. So do I have
to do a --
-You have to do the dolphin.
-A menacing dolphin?
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitates menacing dolphin
squeaking ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitates dolphin ]
Oh, wait. You spray.
Here, you spray.
Yep. Go.
-Ready?
-Yep.
Okay.
-Go. Go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
[ Imitating dolphin squeaking ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ooh.
Wow!
That is me!
That's my favorite right there.
Ooh, I love it!
Michelle Pfeiffer, everybody!
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Check out Henry Rose
in stores nationwide
and at henryrose.com.
We'll be right back
with Bobby Flay. Stick around.